bonsoir à smam à la merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france pourquoi
cette décision américaine intervient tel
maintenant l'histoire
ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'en réalité en
écoutant à brugnaut bruno le maire on
était à quelques à quelques instants de
trouver un accord international au sein
ocde
et ce n'est absolument pas du tout
aujourd'hui dans l'intérêt des états
unis de trouver ce fameux accord sur la
taxation générale et pour comprendre un
tout petit peu ce qui se passe en termes
de stratégie commerciale aux états unis
il faut prendre un tout petit peu
peut-être de distance
m n être pas dans l'émotion européenne
et dans cette déception
est-ce qu'on voit quand même depuis
quelques années à paraître c'est une fin
tout de même donné au mercantilisme
c'est-à-dire un protectionnisme très
fort des marchés intérieurs et une
guerre économique qui n'est pas crainte
mais qui aujourd'hui réel entre deux
pôles qui sont aujourd'hui la chine et
les états unis qui signe le retour dans
pire qu'ils ont très agressif qui ont
une vision hégémonique très claire du
monde et l'europe se retrouve un tout
petit peu coincé entre ces deux pôles
l'un est plutôt dans une forme de
dépendance très très forte vis-à-vis des
des états unis il se trouve que les gars
femmes et les biftecks en général sont
les bras armé est à la fois pour la
chine et pour les états unis de ceux de
cette nouvelle politique commerciale qui
est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui sur les
marchés
alors l'os est de 1,5 at elle des
risques d'une guerre commerciale est ce
que vous aussi vous y croyez c'est pas
qu'on y croise et qu on y est et c'est
un tout petit peu ça qui est toujours
qui est toujours étonnant dans les
discours c'est que ce n'est plus du tout
aujourd'hui au stade de l'inquiétude
on est au stade de la réelle émergence
et d'une reconfiguration du marché
mondial qui n'est en réalité pas du tout
un marché puisqu'un marché c'est bien
tard c'est bien un espace virtuel de
rencontre d'une offre et d'une demande
mais aujourd'hui on est réellement sur
le retour de nouveaux empires plutôt
technologique ou en tout cas les les
grandes les grandes firmes
technologiques en sont les bras armé
d'une vraie vision hégémonique du monde
et qui s'organise autour de la dette
donc ce qu'on appelle le data montre
aujourd'hui tout l'enjeu est de 2 et des
maîtres sont captation de ces big tech
soie chinoise soit soit américaine
l'ensemble des marchés ou des
territoires pour en extraire et en
capter en capter la donne et qui
aujourd'hui est la source première une
des principales sources de création de
valeur alors vous nous avez dit oui
c'est légitime
voilà on est en guerre commerciale à
sheen dakota et les états unis de
l'autre
il n'empêche voilà il ya l'europe au
milieu avec un bruno le maire ministre
français des finances qui ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille et kylie qui tient
lui à sa taxe qu'est ce que ça peut
donner est ce qu'il va réaliser ses
ambitions d'enfin taxer ces géants du
numérique sa langue ou alors au niveau
au niveau de la france donc de
l'état-nation français en effet on a
cette marotte depuis quelque chose comme
deux ans et bruno le maire il tient
absolument à l'or c'est une histoire un
peu et gothique comme avec le stop
coville et cedric haut c'est à dire que
tout d'un coup ça devient une histoire
vraiment d'honneur et sous prétexte
toujours de cette posture un peu dans le
discours politicienne autour de la
souveraineté
alors il se trouve que il va quand même
un jour falloir revenir de ce dogme de
la souveraineté puisque concrètement la
souveraineté aujourd'hui ne sert qu à
faire le lit de discours politiques
légèrement démagogique mais que ça nous
renvoie à aucune réalité et on le voit
c'est à dire qu'en fin d'année dernière
on a renouvelé la dgsi a renouvelé son
contrat avec palantines là on a un
énorme sujet avec le data robe qui dont
les données de santé de l'ensemble des
français vont être stockés par le cloud
d'amazon est donc sous juridiction
américaine
à l'aune du claous tracts donc en
réalité on a en effet un exécutif qui
joue beaucoup sur le la question de la
souveraineté de la taxe etc
mais il me semble que c'est dispo là
sont un tout petit peu suranné sont très
très marquée 20e siècle et la régulation
aujourd'hui des méta plateforme qui sont
de réels monopole qui fonctionne sur des
modèles économiques et algorithmique
très spécifiques et très nouveau doivent
en fait faire preuve de davantage de
créativité et aujourd'hui on a un
certain de piste qui tour absolument à
deux pas du tout punitif ou réactifs
donc de l'ordre de l'impôt mais qui sont
plus de l'ordre
comment est ce que on peut profiter de
ces infrastructures informationnel pour
en faire des robes d'open source qu'il
profiterait aux usages et aux
entreprises tierces aux start up aux
services publics etc
donc on a d'autres moyens de profiter de
cette manne de cette richesse et de la
puissance des données que deux que
d'être en permanence dans la dans la
dans la réaction et dans l'imposition et
dans la réponse fiscale permanente qui
est devenu un réflexe pavlovien très
très français est très européen mais ça
l'est d'ailleurs en france à l'intérieur
de la france enfin il n'empêche avec le
gouvernement français espère quand même
collecté 500 millions d'euros chaque
année grâce à cette taxe c'est quand
même un manque à gagner on a entendu
tous les ateliers à faire preuve de
créativité mais c'est ça serait utile
cet argent quand même pour le pays quand
même d'une certaine manière légitime
alors si on veut parler de la question
de la fiscalité qui est absolument
légitime si on est toujours dans les
réflexions autour d'un périmètre d'un
état nation qui doit renflouer ses
caisses pour financer un certain nombre
de dépenses collectives et pourquoi pas
un certain nombre de services publics
rend fou et l'état social
on sort d'une crise sanitaire majeure en
ce sens pourquoi pas mais à ce moment là
le le sujet beaucoup plus large que
simplement les gaffes ou les 500
millions dégâts phares qui sont par
parenthèse extrêmement ridicule au
regard des regards des du chiffre
d'affaires
aujourd'hui que produisent les gars
femmes en europe donc déjà il ya un
problème dans le calcul de ces fameux 3%
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
capable la doxa où la doctrine de la
régulation européenne n'est pas encore à
jour pour trouver la bonne maille pour
comprendre vraiment comment taxer
proprement ces acteurs du numérique
d'une part et que d'autre part c'est un
sujet qui est beaucoup plus large que
les gars fin c'est le sujet général de
l'évasion fiscale de l'ensemble en fait
des entreprises qui aujourd'hui ont
besoin de frontières et ont besoin que
que deux que qu'il n'y ait pas
finalement d'accord internationaux pour
pouvoir avoir du doping fils y est
fiscal et pour pouvoir aller implantées
si vous voulez leurs sièges sociaux à
droite à gauche en irlande dans les îles
caïman et c'est de façon pouvoir
profiter justement de ces écarts fiscaux
merci beaucoup à ce mal à maître de
conférences à sciences po spécialiste
des enjeux de l'économie numérique
d'avoir été avec nous